>> Tucker: WELL, SINCE THE
ARREST OF THE LONG-TIME DONALD
TRUMP ADVISER ROGER STONE THE
PRESS HAVE RALLIED AROUND
THOSE WHO ARRESTED HIM AND
SPECIFIC INTERPRETATION OF
EVENTS.
THEY SAY IT WAS JUSTIFIED FOR
THE F.B.I. TO SHOW UP TO
OVERTHROW A CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRY.
STONE SAYS HE WAS UPSET BY ALL
THAT, HE MUST BE LYING.
>> F.B.I. HAD INFORMATION TO
HE MIGHT TRY TO DESTROY
EVIDENCE.
SO THEY WENT IN WITH AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
ABREMENTION.
>> THEY HAD EVERY REASON TO
BELIEVE HE WOULD DESTROY
EVIDENCE.
HE THREATENED WITNESSES OR A
WITNESS.
HE WAS PLAYING WITH THE
HARDBALL FACTS.
>> HOW DOES HE DIFFER FROM
OTHER PEOPLE WITH A RAID BY
THE F.B.I.?
NOT THAT DIFFERENT.
THE GUY SPENT THE ENTIRE DAY
IN FRONT OF THE NEWS CAMERAS.
CLEARLY HE WAS TRAUMATIZED.
>> Tucker: WHO PUT THAT GUY
ON TV?
IT'S A DISGRACE.
THE FORMER C.I.A. DIRECTOR
JOHN BRENNAN SPEAKING OF
DISGRACE INSINUATED THAT STONE
WAS HANNIBAL LECTOR LONG LOST
COUSIN.
>> KEEPING WITH THE PROCEDURES
OF THE F.B.I., THEY WERE
CONDUCTING AN ARREST AND
EXECUTING SEARCH WARRANT.
LET'S NOT FORGET ROGER STONE
HAS FAIR AMOUNT OF UNSTABLE
ACTIVITIES AND COMMENTS HE
MADE.
STEALING SOMEONE'S DOG.
TELLING SOMEONE "PREPARE TO
DIE."
THIS IS NOT SOMEBODY TO TRIFLE
WITH.
>> Tucker: TRIFLE.
BRENNAN WHO YOU SAW TALKING
ONCE LIED TO THE PUBLIC, YOU
ME AND THE REST OF US ABOUT
KILLING CIVILIANS WITH DRONE
BOMBS.
BUT THAT IS NOT A BIG DEAL.
HE STILL GOT A CABLE CONTRACT.
WHAT DOES ROGER STONE HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THE COVERAGE OF HIS
ARREST?
WE'LL ASK HIM.
HE IS ON THE SET TONIGHT.
ROGER STONE, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
ARE YOU UNDER A GAG ORDER?
>> NO.
THE JUDGE SAID TODAY SHE IS
CONSIDERING ONE.
SHE ASKED FOR THE GOVERNMENT
AND THE ATTORNEYS TO SUBMIT
THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT.
I'M GOING TO REFRAIN FROM
SPEAKING ABOUT THE SPECIFICS
OF THE INDICTMENT BECAUSE I
ADDRESSED IT IN THE EXTENT I'M
GOING TO.
I'M INTERESTED IN WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
ONE OF MY NEIGHBORS NOW SIGNED
SWORN AFFIDAVIT WHO WAS
WALKING THEIR DOG.
THE CNN CREW, THE STRUCK
SHOWED UP HALF AN HOUR OR 35
MINCE BEFORE THE F.B.I.
I LIVE ON A DEAD END STREET.
THE STREET WAS SEALED.
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO STAY IN
THE POSITION IN FRONT OF MY
HOUSE.
IF I WAS DANGEROUS, WHICH IS
THE PREMISE OF THIS RAID, WHY
WERE THEY ALLOWED TO STAY
WITHIN THE DANGER ZONE?
WHY WERE THEY PUT IN HARM'S
WAY?
THE IDEA I'M A FLIGHT RISK IS
RIDICULOUS.
I DON'T HAVE A VALID PASSPORT.
ALTHOUGH I SUPPORT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT I DON'T OWN A GUN.
THERE WERE NO FIREARMS IN THE
HOUSE.
I HAVE BEEN UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR TWO YEARS.
SO WHAT INFORMATION DID THE
F.B.I. HAVE I WOULD DESTROY
EVIDENCE?
WHY WOULD I WAIT --
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
BRENNAN WHO IS A LIAR, JOHN
BRENNAN DOG KIDNAPPING.
>> I'LL ADDRESS THAT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
I HAVE WRITTEN ON ANIMAL
WELFARE RIGHTS FOR THE DAILY
CALLER AND I WORKED HARD TO
STOP THE GOVERNMENT CONDUCTING
INHUMANE SCIENTIFIC
EXPERIMENTS ON DOGS AND CATS.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU ARE A
DOG LOVER OF THE FIRST --
>> JOHN BRENNAN PURGERRED
HIMSELF TWICE BEFORE THAT.
THE STEELE DICIER AND THE FISA
WARRANT -- STEELE DOZIER AND
THE FISA WARRANT.
AND BREAKING IN THE COMPUTERS
TO LOOK INTO TORTURE BY THE
C.I.A.
>> Tucker: MISLYING ABOUT
KILLING PEOPLE WITH DRONES.
>> BUT HE IS NOT PROSECUTED.
LIKE MR. COMEY, MR. McCABE,
ROD ROSENSTEIN, MR. WRAY.
GENERAL CLAPPER, OF COURSE,
WHO SAID NO, THERE IS NO
METADATA COLLECTION PROCESS.
THEN HILLARY CLINTON HERSELF.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE PURGERRED
THEMSELVES BUT I -- PURGERRED
THEMSELVES.
>> Tucker: ASK ABOUT THE DAY
OF THE ARREST, A WEEK AGO
TODAY.
YOU SAID CNN WAS IN THE
PERIMETER AND THAT WAS A RAID
THAT MUST HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED
DANGEROUS.
THERE WERE AUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
ONE HAD TWO SIDE ARM.
A LOT OF GUNS.
WHY WERE THEY ALLOWED TO STAY
THERE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I HOPE SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND THE REPUBLICANS WOULD GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHO
SIGNED OFF ON THE RAID.
THE MAIN REASON THAT THE GAG
ORDER CONCERNS ME IS BECAUSE I
NEED TO BE ABLE TO RAISE THE
MONEY TO MOUNT A DEFENSE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THEY HAVE UNLIMITED
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS.
THREE PLATOONS OF LEFT WING
IVY LEAGUE LAWYERS TO
PROSECUTE ME.
THEY HAVE ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL IN DISCOVERY WE HAVE
TO GO THROUGH.
THREE TERABYTE ACCORDING TO
THE PRESS RELIEF.
SO UNLESS THEY GO TO
STONEDEFENSEFUND.com AND I
HAVE A FORUM TO PROMOTE IT I
DON'T --
>> Tucker: I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT GROUNDS COULD THEY END
YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS?
>> THEY GAGGED PAUL MANAFORT
IN HIS TRIAL.
BECAUSE I WOULD BE PREJUDICING
WITNESSES.
PARDONING ME.
I'D BE PREJUDICING A JURY.
WHAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF THE
RAID TO POISON THE JURY AND
HOLD ME UP AS PUBLIC ENEMY
NUMBER ONE.
>> Tucker: TO USE CABLE NEWS
CHANNEL AS A P.R. OPERATION TO
GET THEIR MESSAGE OUT.
IF THEY GAG YOU AND TAKE YOUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AWAY,
DOES IT MEAN THEY ARE NO
LONGER ALLOWED TO LEAK TO CNN
AGAINST YOU?
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
THE PURPOSE OF THE GAG IS SO I
DON'T POISONED A POTENTIAL
JURY POOL.
THEY HAVE POISONED THE JURY
POOL BUT COMPARING ME TO PABLO
ESCOBAR.
>> Tucker: IT'S ONE-SIDED.
THEY CAN ARREST YOU WITH THE
ARMORED VEHICLES AND THE STUN
GRENADES AND FORCE YOU NOT TO
SPEAK IN PUBLIC.
BUT THEY CAN STILL SAY
WHATEVER THEY WANT ABOUT YOU
TO NEWS ORGANIZATIONS.
>> AND LEAK.
I MEAN IN TWO YEARS OF LEAKS
AS YOU KNOW I WAS GOING TO BE
ARRESTED EVERY OVER TUESDAY
DESTROYED MY BUSINESS.
THE CENSORSHIP OF MY SHOW ON
INFO WARS.
AND THE CENSORSHIP OF MY
FACEBOOK PAGE HAS HURT MY BOOK
SALES DRAMATICALLY.
I'M A "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR.
SO THIS IS PART OF THE PLAN.
DESTROY YOU FINANCIALLY SO
LIKE GENERAL FLYNN YOU HAVE TO
PLEAD GUILTY TO SOMETHING YOU
DIDN'T DO.